Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters with Michelle Hamburger. Hello, and we're going to address a question today
We've got a little a grief that by picture down here in the quarter is a few years old
So I thought I would change it. Thought that'd be better
Such a handsome is that a bow tie?
You look very happy to be wearing it. Yeah, well, it was a fairly big shirt. You know what that age?
If you're not really keen for fairly pictures, I'm sure. So yeah, the photographer is getting some serious evil eye from you.
Okay, so we had a question about what?
Yeah, so we've had a few patients and non-patients who have let us know that they've heard from other
I don't know if they're medical practitioners or just people that they were respecting their opinion
and they've been saying that using the rife when you're doing chemo is a bad thing to do that it can actually
you know, it won't benefit you to use them in conjunction with each other. So wanting to clarify that.
Yeah, we've heard from a lot of people, well, a lot of people, maybe half a dozen over the last couple of years about
Somebody told me I should use the rife while I'm doing chemo and I think that's a misunderstanding of what the rife does.
When you're doing chemo, chemo understand as a poison, a poison as an oxidizing agent.
So typically we don't want to do any antioxidants if we're doing chemo.
There are some limitations to that statement and we'll talk about that in another member's minute.
But the rife is not an antioxidant agent so the rife is not contraindicated with chemo therapy.
Matter of fact, I think on the contrary what the rife does is there's multiple theories on what using frequency generator
like frequency does to a cancer but certainly disputedly it causes that cancer cell to vibrate.
It can cause that cancer to uptake nutrients more so especially stimulated immune system against itself.
And that's the whole purpose of the rife. You're trying to stimulate an immune response against that cancer.
That's not an antioxidant response so understand what that means.
Also, we want the chemo to work on the cancer cells.
And I think when you use the rife, you help target the chemo to the cancer.
Promise the chemo is not necessarily targeted to cancer, right? It's going to your whole body, right?
So the danger of chemo is that it's killing healthy cells and that's what makes us sick.
And that's what damages our immune response and that's what causes our hair to fall out.
If we're going to put a poison in our body, we want it to be attracted to the cancer cells.
By using the rife along with the chemo, I think you're going to have a greater degree of targeting or attracted from the cancer cell to the chemo.
So I think it can be a huge benefit to couple the rife with chemotherapy.
If you're going to do chemotherapy, do the rife at the same time, not the same time you're getting the infusion necessarily.
But that's flowing through your bloodstream, that chemotherapy and it's in your body.
If you go home and do the rife, I think it's going to target the cancer cells much better.
You're going to have a better result of the chemotherapy, that's my belief.
So we want the chemo to work as best as possible.
We want the chemo to target the cancer cells as best as possible.
And we want the chemo to leave the healthy cells alone as best as possible.
And I think the rife does a wonderful job in that.
So the only contraindication regarding the rife and its attachments that we would have more in association with doing chemo is at what point in time during your chemo session are you doing the ion pro wave?
The ion pro wave, the purpose of the ion pro wave is to have the program you're running with it obviously.
But typically we have cancer patients run detoxification programs with the ion pro wave.
So it is contraindicated to run the ion pro wave with detoxification programs for about 48 hours after you receive chemo.
Or if you're on a chemo that you're taking every day, well then we might want to talk about that again.
How strongly is it pulling the chemo out of you?
That's a question of debate.
If you're doing a chemo that's lasting five days and you're off three weeks, I would not do the foot bath for those five days and I would wait another 48 hours after those five days before I do the foot baths again.
Most people are doing chemo infusions for one given day and then I would wait after you come home from the clinic from that infusion I'd wait 48 hours before I do a detox program or hit the detox supplements real hard.
So that's a different story. You're not running cancer frequencies when you're doing that ion foot bath necessarily.
What we're talking about is using the right running cancer frequency. So it's affecting those cancer cells and I believe strongly that it will increase the effectiveness of the chemotherapy.
And that's what we want. You're going to do chemotherapy. We want it to work and I think the right helps that.
And we want it to work with the least amount of chemotherapy possible.
Sure. So well, thank you very much. That makes perfect sense. All right. Bye-bye.